heart-rending scenes in rural kentucky
as intense rain storms have caused
flooding day after day in mountain
valleys many people in the impoverished
region have seen all their possessions
washed away we've lost four houses um a
couple of vehicles all our farm
equipment
i mean technically
there's nothing else left for us to lose
my home's gone
my new home i just bought from my four
children is gone
so i had to start from scratch all over
again
even worse the floods have claimed at
least 30 lives
these children were ripped from their
mother's arms by the rushing water all
four siblings drowned
the death toll is expected to rise there
are hundreds of unaccounted for people
minimum and we just we just don't have a
firm grasp on that i wish we did
more than twelve thousand people are
without electricity and there is more
rain on the way
intense weather events like the one in
kentucky are a consequence of global
heating scientists say this is exactly
the fingerprint the signature that we
would expect with global warming due to
the increase in greenhouse gases from
human activities
as the atmosphere warms the air can hold
more moisture unleashing epic storms
in las vegas the desert city better
known for casinos than catastrophes
thunderstorms inundated the famous strip
and flooded hotels
when conditions are right we can get
these catastrophic rain events several
inches per hour from flood to fire
in northern california a wildfire
sparked on friday grew to consume more
than 23 square kilometers of forest land
the biggest blaze in the state this year
firefighters found two people dead in a
burned out car in their home's driveway
firefighters say years of drought and
unusually high temperatures also linked
to global warming have created more
intense and fast-moving fires
the biden administration and democrats
in congress are pushing a bill to reduce
greenhouse gas emissions and move toward
clean energy but senate republicans
including their leader mitch mcconnell
part of whose own state of kentucky is
under water oppose the climate
legislation
for those affected by the back-to-back
disasters sweeping the country the
legislation is far too little too late
rob reynolds al jazeera